cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com Senate Majority Leader Chuck
Schumer quietly ditches dress code to
cater for Pennsylvania Democrat John
fetterman and his shorts and hoodies
this is just I mean like dude come on
man you want to wear you want to wear a
hoodie with Jim with jogging shorts that
I do not feel is appropriate however I
don't necessarily I mean this is it is
silly it looks like he got lost and
wandered in there right and so my issue
is this
first I agree with everybody when
they're like
don't change the rules for one dude it's
like yeah okay there is no formal dress
code it doesn't exist it's basically
just who's ever the the Senate leader
just determines if you're into Quorum or
whatever but they typically require
coats and ties I disagree with that I
also disagree with fetterman wearing gym
short jogging shorts and hoodies that's
silly but I I do think we shouldn't have
we we shouldn't demand this like Elite
decorum of suit wearing and special
dresses and all that stuff so my
attitude is um
you should be dressed appropriately
meaning the the dress code should be
something like uh you have to wear pants
you have to wear shoes you have to wear
a shirt we you could you can be removed
if you are determined to be like uh
unkempt or something like that but I
don't agree overall with the uh the
standard dress code people expect you
know suit wearing and stuff and so the
important thing to consider is we kick
the segment off Donald Trump ate a well
done steak with ketchup it was a 30 day
dry age steak at a fancy restaurant and
they said how do you want it says well
done with ketchup
and the media mocked and insulted him
for it but Trump is smart he laid the
Trap when the media came out and started
insulting Trump for for eating a steak
well done with ketchup a lot of poor
people in this country eat their steaks
well done with ketchup they can't afford
the good fancy 30-day dry aged steaks
they want something that just tastes
good and they slap some ketchup on it
and that's that's for some people not
everybody you know there are poor people
who understand the Finer Things in life
and know how to make a good steak I'm
not saying that's not true but right now
the the Democrats trying to lay us
they're trying to use fetterman as the
Everyman a guy who's just wearing Odeon
shorts It's the regular working probably
not his real outfit that's what I was
thinking right so exactly he probably
goes home off camera and puts a suit on
and sits in it he probably sits in a
suit in his living room and goes I wish
I could just dress like everyone else in
my they're probably like no John you're
putting on this you're putting on the
hoodie and you're putting on the shorts
that's just get on camera yeah but I
think you have I think in all
seriousness you're probably right to a
certain degree he goes home he doesn't
wear that I bet he wear is just like
jeans and a t-shirt normal clothes and
then he puts on the hoodie and shorts
for a Persona and they want you to
insult him for it because they're hoping
you insult Working Class People in PA
I'm not saying every working class
person in PA wears this but they were I
was seeing a lot of people post on
Twitter saying like hey man a lot of us
up here in Western PA we dress similarly
they have all our data and they did a
poll they have all our data they're
looking they're like hoodie and shorts
and he campaigned in the hoodie too I
mean this has been a consistent thing
for him uh I don't personally think that
there's anything wrong with having
different standards of dress and having
some places where it's more formal and
whatever else and again that might be
like the culture I grew up in right like
I went to I grew up going to church and
everyone wore coat and tie like I'm
comfortable with it I can understand
where it maybe doesn't function as
mandatory like does it make a difference
if your congressman is wearing a tie I
don't know in this case with fetterman I
feel like they're trying to act like
whatever he does is normal because he's
not okay and I think in that way it's
some somewhat insulting to his
constituents right to say that oh well
he's just trying to relate to you
because he also wears a hoodie to work
like no he gets special exceptions
because he has never seemed to really
recover from the stroke he had yes but
most people don't watch the news they
don't pay attention they hear things in
passing that's why CNN does stuff like
despite there being no evidence of a
crime they're they're trying to impeach
Joe Biden which is just not sure there's
tons of evidence of a crime it should be
determined by a jury by first by
Congress in the Senate then by a jury
whether that was Criminal but that's
that
that's the setup I suppose but fetterman
runs one of the most corrupt states in
the whole entire country and all we talk
about is his hoodie and his pain his
someone in his office does run one of
the most corrupt States I'm not sure
it's him yeah I agree I think yeah he's
definitely you know had health health
problems but Pennsylvania is is very
corrupt I mean I I grew up in
Pennsylvania and it's
it's we we should be talking about the
job he's doing too well I mean I love
this conspiracy theory that they swapped
him out with a body double yeah I think
is Alex Stein promoting that one
probably I don't know he loves
conspiracy theories but uh I don't
people because fetterman shaved and he
had a mustache though it's a different
guy and it's like oh come on it's not a
different guy his nose has the same
shape and everything and his ears are
the same and they're like no his ears
are bigger in one photo it's like dude
it's a wide angle versus a long very
unique guy yeah I know right there was
one where like they couldn't see the
tattoo on his arm so they're saying like
oh it's gone so it must be someone else
people just can't believe he won people
can't believe like wow that's the that's
that's the guy in people this is the
issue about people not paying attention
to the news that they can just run a
headline insert something nonsensical
and people just believe it so when it
comes to fetterman the average person
doesn't hear him talk the average person
does not know or care they see a picture
of a dude who's supposed to look like a
regular working-class guy he's he's not
and then when the media attacks him all
they know is like they're attacking John
why what do you do he's like a regular
dude and it's like you're like a stroke
on camera this is happening now they're
having like Strokes on camera and then
be like it wasn't a stroke it's like
they translate for him I saw that it was
a stroke how many times can we see
something with our own eyes and then get
reported that it was not what we saw
that's the point see you watched the
video 90 of people won't yeah so then
what happens is fetterman is sitting in
Senate in in the Senate and he goes why
course
gasoline
it's too much
why
huh and then the the media will then
write in a paragraph John fetterman gave
a passionate and exasperated plea to
lower the price of gas and reduce the
amount of cars on the highway they don't
they won't actually quote what he said
they'll just create an interpretation
then someone will see a picture of John
fetterman going like this like hmm and
then it'll say that and they'll be like
wow and they won't realize that he
didn't actually say anything English I'm
voting for this guy his fingers up well
I mean I'm passionate to be fair Michael
malice said this is this is the guy to
vote for okay buying a hoodie I'm
booting no but you want more uh uh in
incapable individuals in Congress you
want to hold I disagree because who's
Staffing them right like if he's a
puppet someone's someone's maneuver not
he's not a puppet it's that he is in
there confused and bewildered and his
office is in disarray and so if every
member of Congress in the Senate whereas
disheveled and disoriented as fetterman
then the government would just be
stuck well they already are stuck what
happened what do we get the report uh oh
uh we seem to misplace 176 trillion
dollars you guys seen it anywhere like
what happened really there was hundreds
of millions of dollars we just lost a
100 million dollar jet we lost 100
million dollars but there's 20 billion
today I think they lost they did like an
audit of the Pentagon they did something
right and they they found a crazy amount
of missing money and I was like you
should check Ukraine it could be there
is there a website where you can see how
much money was lost today by the US
government no but there should somebody
make that website that'd be nice yeah we
should look at the offshore accounts so
it might have been lost to those
I want to address this about the uniform
uh because Kane Abel super chatted
saying that wearing a suit and ties
about respect for the office and and
those and those that represent it's not
about a leadish behavior how many suits
do you own how many suits do you own one
one suit yep how many suits do you own
one how many Ian they're out like seven
jackets how many suits do you own no I
don't know I have one suit one suit it's
a disco suit and I should wear it
they're very old and they don't fit very
well anymore I don't own any Suits now
you have one one if you're going to be
in session where you have to be wearing
a suit every day one's not gonna cut it
you're gonna need a couple more right
how much that suit costs it was
expensive yeah too much it's a good one
it's a good one uh but but they have
affordable suits for people who you
don't want to break the bank uh I would
also assume the average person probably
if you couldn't afford if you're living
Patriot to paycheck you're probably
gonna have to go to a thrift store to
buy a suit I'm not saying suits the
hardest things in the world to get I
just don't like the idea of some
arbitrary cultural standard of what you
must now own to represent Working Class
People or anyone in this country suits
in my view are this this social custom
of I am wearing a thing because we have
deemed this to be the thing you have to
wear in this setting it doesn't mean
anything to me I would rather see a dude
in in his work overalls with grease on
his hands in the Senate building saying
I got off work 20 minutes ago and I'm
not going to drive an hour back and
forth just so that I can put on a suit
for you this is what real working class
Americans look like instead we get
clammy hands frail dainty
multi-millionaires doing insider trading
wearing their suits and demanding here's
the worst part here's what what I hate
about this okay fine you want to make an
argument everyone's got to dress up
that's fine the problem is this my
compromise is you want a dress code for
fetterman they have to pay for it you
can't mandate someone but then what
about what about visitors what about
people who want to testify you want to
go and testify we have a dress code you
can't come in unless you're wearing a
suit the expectation that every person
in this country is going to have access
to these things now again I will stress
I'm not saying it's the hardest thing in
the world to get a suit but I just don't
like the idea that there could be a
circumstance where we want a farmer to
testify and he says look man I'm in the
field 16 hours a day I ain't got no time
to go out and get get a tailor fit suit
or find a suit maybe I can borrow one
but if they want to come in and they
want to show what it actually is like to
be the person who is the foundation of
this country producing the things that
make this country good then or make this
country function then I think it's fine
to say okay maybe you shouldn't have
grease on your hands wash your hands in
the bathroom clear that off but if
you're going to show up showing the
American people this is what it looks
like when you work for this country I
find that acceptable and I don't like
that they're like you can't come into
our Elite chamber because you represent
this country so you have to wear the
clothes we determine you can wear well
and I
larger cultural change I mean we used to
be a more formal Society men used to
wear hats like there were all kinds of
things that we used to do that still
cling on some parts of society and don't
exist everywhere right like a hundred
years ago hoodies didn't exist people
still got dressed they wore something
else I mean there was a time when there
was an expectation of dress code that
was just different and maybe it's good
that our culture has changed but I don't
think that like it has to be elite I
think you're right that people should be
able to come shouldn't be excluded
especially if it's going to affect their
daily lives because they don't have a
suit I got no problem with you have to
wear pants you have to wear shoes you
have to wear a shirt and you have to be
clean I can totally understand all those
things there's questions of hygiene and
I do respect to a great degree the idea
of professionalism I don't respect the
idea of the arbitrary suit as the symbol
of what it is to be professional because
I view a working class American in his
maybe it's a mechanic and he's wearing a
jumpsuit that to me is more indicative
of someone who works for this country
than these I'm going to refrain from
cussing and insulting these pieces of
trash these corporate funded sellouts
who don't actually represent you and
your values and sell your values out to
the highest bidder what would you take
very little respect for these people and
to be like it's the clothing they wear
that shows professionalism uh that I'm
sorry dude how about this every one of
these people has to wear the outfit that
is deemed that is the average worker's
clothing in the state they come from
they sold us out to the max it feels
that way right now right now today I
feel like we've been sold out to the max
by the people that are in charge I feel
like it's I feel that way personally I'm
like man they every time they get
together they don't make the right
decision for the civilians and the
people every single time and just like
what you're saying you're having a hard
time even not saying bad things about
those you want to lose your mind you
want to be like these but it's a bright
attitude none of this is where we are
right now thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time